good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast the red list has
returned a new coronavirus variant which
is causing increasing concern and has
been described as the worst one yet has
led to six southern african countries
being added to the uk's travel red list
flights from the nations will be
suspended from midday today so just how
worried should we be and will the
measures stop the variants reaching our
shores we'll be speaking to the
transport secretary grant shaps in a few
minutes time
and tragedy in the channel the prime
minister's plea to france's president
for british officials on french beaches
also this morning we'll speak to the
actress victoria eckenoy who was
diagnosed with breast cancer and is now
campaigning for better screening centers
for women across the country
[Music]
and smoke's back on the water's deep
purple return with a new album we'll
speak to the band's frontman ian gillen
about their surprise release
it's friday the 26th of november
the red list returns flights to the uk
from six african countries will be
suspended from midday over a new covert
variant described as the worst so far
as the south african government says the
travel ban's been rushed
the prime minister asks president macron
to allow british border force staff to
conduct joint patrols on french beaches
from next week after 27 people died in
the channel
sky news speaks to the family of an
iraqi man who hasn't been heard from
since he told them he was heading into
british waters on wednesday
a new build to improve the lives of
people with down syndrome receives
government support
for three months
she was potentially really struggling
but no one listened to me
and that and that is you know there's
nowhere for you to go
storm arwin will bring disruptive winds
and some winteriness today and tomorrow
but sunday looks calmer and drier
[Music]
good morning flights to the uk from six
southern african countries will be
suspended from midday as the government
takes action to try and ensure a new
covid variant does not reach the uk
the variant discovered in botswana could
be more infectious and more resistant to
vaccines and one expert has described it
as the worst we've seen so far
the south african government has
responded calling the uk's decision to
ban travel from south africa as rushed
sky's iva bennett has the story
it is a worrying reminder that the
pandemic is far from over just weeks
after the final travel restrictions were
lifted the red list has reappeared
six african nations subject to a travel
ban in response to the spread of a
variant dubbed the worst seen so far
it may be more transmissible than the
delta variant
and it and the vaccines that we
currently have may be less effective
against it now to be clear we have not
detected any of this new variant in the
uk at this point in time
but we've always been clear that we will
take action to protect the progress that
we have made
from midday all flights from south
africa namibia lozotto botswana
eastwatini and zimbabwe will be
suspended anyone arriving from those
countries after 4 am on sunday will have
to quarantine in a hotel those returning
before then must isolate at home while
passengers who have come back in the
last 10 days are being asked to take a
pcr test
the new variant has around 30 mutations
twice as many as the delta variant which
could make it more transmissible and
more capable of evading vaccine immunity
only 59 cases have been confirmed so far
mostly in one south african province but
officials there are fearing a rapid
nationwide spread
from the experience of the last 21
months or so we almost can predict how
this is going to move you can be rest
assured as people start to move even
more over the next few weeks this will
be all over
much is still unknown about the variant
and just how fast it may spread but
given past experience the government is
taking no chances either bennett sky
news
antiglio de oliveira the director of the
center for epidemic response and
innovation in south africa that found
the new variant tweeted saying busy day
on a variant of great concern the world
should provide support to south africa
and africa and not discriminate or
isolate it
by protecting and supporting it we will
protect the world a plea for
billionaires and financial institutions
well the transport secretary grant shaps
uh joins me now a very good morning
to you mr shaps south africa has
responded calling this decision to ban
flights temporarily as rushed how would
you respond to that
well look i think we know from dealing
with coronavirus all this time that
actually the the kind of early bird
catches the worms as it were it's
important to make sure that you do act
immediately
and in doing so you get to slow things
down in terms of potential entry into
the country and that gives us a bit of
time for the scientists to work on
sequencing the genome which involves
growing cultures and takes several weeks
to do so we can find out how significant
concern this particular variant is so it
is a safety first uh approach we've done
that before with things like the mink
variant from denmark and then able to
relax it unreasonably quickly and i
think it's a preference for doing that
rather than waiting and seeing until
it's too late
but but between five and seven hundred
people fly to the uk every day from
south africa alone what about those
people who arrived in the last 24 hours
and who could be carrying that variant
already
yeah i should say we haven't actually
detected any in the uk at all as yet um
but we're contacting those people
specifically that works already underway
to make sure that they're taking pcr
tests and we're getting the extra
checks um done so we're able to contact
each of those individuals through the
passenger locator form of course if
you're watching this and you have
returned from south africa then please
be in contact with test and trace please
take a pcr test um straight away and
they will be contacting you uh but uh
you know we just thought that this is a
as scientists have described a the most
significant variant they've encountered
to date in their uh research and i want
to actually thank the south african uh
government for um their great work in
helping to uncover this is very much a
precautionary approach but i think it
makes sense and i think that uh the
wider population will will uh sort of
appreciate that we're acting quickly
because we don't want to have the chance
of uh we want to give ourselves every
opportunity uh to be able to research
this uh before it uh becomes uh you know
common here
now it's suggested that vaccines could
be 40
less effective against this new variant
you say you're contacting people and
inviting them for a pcr test these tests
won't be enforced then
so the that we certainly will be um uh
contacting every single person who's
coming back and asking for a test
remember that it's still a relatively
small outbreak uh in south africa uh but
that it's growing very very quickly so
we need to learn about the severity of
the transmissibility of it uh and of
course most critically of all how
vaccines susceptible it is in other
words whether it can escape the vaccine
or not um but we're tracking down each
person who's who's come here as i say
we've we've got no signs that it's here
yet uh it's still relatively small in
south africa but this precautionary
approach similar to the one we took with
the mink variant in denmark
i think is the right way to go whilst we
get answers you could i hope this simply
becomes a pause in uh travel from south
africa and those other uh countries uh
but we do need to do this work first and
this is the precautionary approach to
make sure we have time to do it
now we're very fortunate here the uk is
moving fast with booster vaccines unlike
uh the situation in many countries in
the developing world is vaccine
inequality one of the main reasons that
we're seeing the emergence of these new
variants
well i think um the united kingdom's got
a very proud record with that oxford
astrazeneca vaccine because that's the
one that globally has been distributed
particularly to the developing world um
faster than any other um i i haven't got
a recent figure the last one i saw was a
billion and a half doses of it um being
distributed um and of course it's being
done at cost because astrazeneca said
they wouldn't make a profit from um
doing it and of course it was it was
british expertise at oxford university
so i think this country um it has done a
remarkable amount as well as putting
money into the international vaccine
program as well
perhaps there i say more than any other
country given uh the distribution of
that cost vaccine to the whole world
now one of the reasons uh variants are
detected so well in south africa is
because they have such great
genomic sequencing we can't be 100
sure that this variant isn't already in
the uk or indeed within europe so why
does the government not uh enforce uh
face masks in areas such as public
transport or in shops like we see in so
many other
countries well one of the things that's
kind of interesting here is that we've
seen because as you rightly say the huge
take-up of vaccines very little um sort
of skepticism about vaccines in this
country unlike unlike elsewhere
may not be effective against this new
variant it may be far less effective
and that that is of course the concern
but i was going to say and the booster
uptake it's now touching on nearly 30
percent of people have had their
boosters you can't even have that until
it's six months after your uh first
vaccine but the uptake has been so good
that we have created a
something of a wall of protection now we
do have a plan b which is well
publicized that if we need to go to that
we we will and that includes uh mask
wearing uh everywhere and the like uh
and and more besides but we don't want
we want people to be able to live their
lives we want the economy to be able to
flourish we want people to be able to go
about their business and see their
friends and family so we're trying to
operate as permissive you know
atmosphere as possible uh but of course
we're keeping a very close eye on this
all the time so far in our numbers we
haven't seen any reason to do uh
anything else and it has to be said
considering we've been unlocked since
the 19th of july um that i think we've
been right to go about in in this way
and uh you know
fortunately uh the figures move around
uh there are certainly plenty of cases
each day but those cases are translating
into hospitalizations and deaths at a
much lower rate
than elsewhere
okay let me just move on to the
situation in the channel if i may mr
shaps now of course the prime minister
wrote to president macron uh suggesting
various points that he thinks would
improve the situation including some
sort of return arrangement now we had
one of those
when we were a member of the european
union we don't anymore why wasn't it
negotiated along with brexit before we
left
well i mean look the the negotiations
with the eu um were carried out against
the backdrop of whatever the eu and
whatever we could agree or clearly
that's the upshot of the negotiation i
don't think it's quite clear that uh
that with the old arrangement um it
would have stopped what's happening now
people were coming across remember when
we were in the eu they were coming
across primarily for many years via
lorries what's really changed here is
that because in calais and elsewhere
they've blocked off the route to jumping
in the back of the lorry a lot of it's
been fenced off that is not now the sort
of chosen route in we've got much better
at detecting people in lorries instead
people are using this incredibly
perilous route of the north sea which is
unbelievably dangerous it's run by
criminal gangs
and sadly very sadly this week we've
seen the upshot of taking that very
dangerous route in but i think it's a
mistake to think that it wasn't
happening before it's been happening for
for many many years it's the route
that's changed and that's why the prime
minister's written to president macron
uh with
five different
ideas which could help redouble the
efforts and invitation to to meet up to
discuss it as well
but
your government
won the last election
on a ticket when it came to brexit and
taking back control but the reality is
when it comes to protecting our borders
we're very much reliant on france and
other european
countries and we're now negotiating from
a position of weakness what's in it for
france suggesting some sort of return
agreement now would we accept
refugees in return uh being returned
from france
well i i think it is i i have to say a
bit of a red herring to mix this up with
um brexit it's not even actually an
argument that i've heard before and as
of explain there were plenty of uh
people attempting the crossing before
they just happen to be doing it in
different ways including by lorries
what's what's different here is the
number of people who are doing it by um
c but uh i think the europe arguments
are uh you know uh confusing here
because it's not related to that this is
you know i think
heartbreaking to to see and i think it's
incumbent on the united kingdom and
france to do whatever's required to
resolve this uh
and and get get on top of this human
tragedy um but there's international law
that governs things not european law or
international law that governs things
people should be claiming asylum in the
first free country for example
and since france is a free country
indeed since people will
many times travel through many other
countries first and that is where the
asylum should be uh claimed uh but then
of course we've got our
our immigration borders um bill which is
designed to deal with a lot of what uh
the french call the pull factors to the
united kingdom uh and that's making its
way through parliament and i'm very much
hoping that despite what we've seen so
far with the opposition voting against
it i hope they will support that bill
because it would be one of the fastest
ways to
ensure that uh for example asylum
applications uh need to be made uh from
outside the country and that you know
when uh people uh come here uh via an
illegal route they know that
that isn't a route that you can make an
asylum application from all of those
things are
included in the borders bill and we
really appreciate cross-party support
for it
okay so you say it's heartbreaking
what's happening in the channel uh well
nearly two days on from 27 people losing
their lives in that crossing
boris johnson pledged urgent action
what's changed
we've had as you know a series of
discussions uh with the with the french
there is more active patrol going on i i
understand on the french beaches and
there was yesterday um uh british patel
the home secretary has spoken to her
counterpart and she's actually going uh
over to france to spend the uh the next
couple of days there uh talking with her
counterparts and the prime minister has
made the offer to join meetings and
upgrade those meetings in fact in his
letter that he's written to president
macron and they've also spoken as well
it's quite clear that we need to
be get on top of this um the issue is
originating
from france it's originating much
earlier than france of course for the
migrants who've made a very dangerous
journey across europe but they're
leaving to come to the uk
from france and it does mean that the
action is required there on the beaches
and we're trying to offer every possible
help including for example uh reciprocal
maritime uh patrols and uh helping each
other out in in territorial water
putting in more
technology to track the boats more
airborne surveillance we can only do
many of these things including setting
up a joint intelligence cell
working with the french
and that's why we're appealing uh to the
french to work closely even closer with
us uh on this it's in all our interests
to get on top of it
and now not as a politician as a human
being your reaction to what you're
seeing
in the channel some saying the channel
is the new mediterranean when it comes
to these dangerous crossings we can do
better than this as a country can't we
but i think it's heartbreaking and i
think it's important to know uh that you
know many many organizations from border
force to the rnli
and others are working day and night
actually day and night to try to save
lives and protect people the best way we
can do that is to stop people from
launching from the french coast in the
first place and the way to do that is to
work together uh in order to
close down these criminal gangs many of
whom have been uh closed down uh i i
think uh
thousands have been stopped i think 16
000 people have been stopped from
crossing the channel
and you know my heart goes out to people
who are desperate enough to to do that
but it is giving money to criminal gangs
who are putting their lives at risk and
we absolutely have to get on top of what
is a human tragedy and we can only do
that with cooperation with the french
okay mr shaps thanks very much indeed
for your time today thank you thank you
well let's return to our top story now
the travel ban imposed on southern
african countries after a new covered
variant was detected in sky's
ashnohrinag is at heathrow airport for
us this morning good morning to you
ashna so what can we expect
well i think it is going to come as
quite a shock for many of the passengers
that are due to land here at heathrow
over the next
few hours many of them will have boarded
last night south africa has a very very
similar time zone to the uk so many of
them won't be aware perhaps of this
announcement coming in regardless of
that as soon as they touch down here in
the uk they are being advised to take a
pcr test such as the concern around this
new variant that's been discovered now
in the past the uk government has been
criticized of course for acting too late
when it comes to travel bans and it's
perhaps uh that that has spurred this
this rush in the view of the south
african government and hence why we're
seeing this new uh decision being taken
at the moment there are 59 cases of this
variant that have been discovered in
south africa it is worth saying though
that coronaviruses mutate all the time
and we only tend to report it when they
are of genuine concern when they proceed
from being a variant of interest to a
variant of concern such is this one but
certainly a uh protective barrier is
being put around the uk if you like by
preventing those arrivals well from test
by testing those arrivals who are coming
into the uk over the next coming hours
okay ash nether now thank you
now still to come on the programme at
around half past seven we'll hear from a
top epidemiologist in south africa as
concern grows over a new covid variant
as the uk and france scramble to find a
solution to the situation in the english
channel i'll be speaking to an officer
from the immigration service union on
what could be done
and at five past eight i'll get
continued reaction to that tragedy in
the channel from the shadow home
secretary nick thomas simmons
[Music]
the prime minister has offered to work
with france to tackle small boat
crossings in the channel and avoid a
repeat of what he called the appalling
tragedy on wednesday which left 27
people dead boris johnson has written to
president emmanuel macron setting out
five steps he thinks both sides should
take as it as soon as possible it comes
after 17 men seven women and two teenage
boys and a teenage girl died near calais
after their boat sank on their way to
the uk sky news spoke to a crew member
of one of the first french lifeboats to
reach the scene
[Music]
now the family of an iraqi man has told
sky news they have not heard from him
since he told them he was heading into
british waters on wednesday
some smugglers say he wasn't on the
dinghy that sank in the english channel
but his family still fears the worst our
middle east correspondent alastair
bunkel reports
shalau's brother got on a boat from
france to england on wednesday around
the same time that the 27 people drowned
in the channel
this was the last voice message that the
family received from him
as he was midway across
foreign
hasn't been heard from since and they
have no idea if he was on board the boat
that capsized like many families here
they're just waiting for news
foreign
[Music]
the kurdish regional government has
confirmed to us that kurds were on board
the boat
but they're still working on numbers and
identities
[Music]
[Music]
last night more kurdish and iraqi
migrants were flown home from belarus
many that we have spoken to here are
unperturbed by failure and not put off
by the deaths in the channel
they will try again
alice debunk the sky news in northern
iraq
a young woman has provided sky news with
hundreds of pages of evidence including
diary extracts photos of injuries and
school welfare logs which document
claims that she was sexually abused by
multiple men as a teenager she's one of
a number of people who say they have
been the victim of an alleged grooming
gang in hull the police investigation
wound down earlier this year without any
charges being brought now in the second
in a series of reports exploring the
difficulty of getting prosecutions in
such cases the woman we are calling anna
explains why she repeatedly returned to
her alleged abusers
the main thing that was in my head was
if i don't do this something worse is
going to happen
and it's just the whole cycle you're in
you just
it's hard to get out of
you just normalized to it
and no one was offering us help to get
us out of it so you kind of think well
it can't be that bad if no one's
bothered
and you can listen to anna's story in
more detail throughout the day here on
sky news
also making the news this morning
proposals to legally guarantee people
with down syndrome have their social
care needs met
have received government support
a bill expected to clear its first
commons hurdle later would help to
support both people with a condition and
their loved ones
sometimes as a parent and speaking to
other parents you kind of feel
that no one has any high expectations
for our children
and it's that old-fashioned stigma for
three months
she was potentially really struggling
but no one listened to me
and that and that is you know there's
nowhere for you to go
time now for a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
storm arwin will bring disruptive winds
and wintry hazards today and tomorrow
but sunday does look calmer and drier
it's the first named storm of the season
with the met office amber wind warning
for eastern scotland and northeast
england exposed coasts there could see
gusts in excess of 75 miles per hour
yellow warnings cover other parts of the
uk too
today we'll start cold and unsettled but
the far southeast will be mainly dry and
frosty with a bit of patchy rain
the government has told sky news this
morning it is taking a safety first
approach when it comes to the new covert
variant discovered in botswana that
follows criticism from south africa that
the decision was rushed the transport
secretary grant shaps told us it's the
most significant variant found to date
it's important to make sure that you do
act immediately
and in doing so you get to slow things
down in terms of potential entry into
the country and that gives us a bit of
time for the scientists to work on uh
sequencing the genome which involves
growing cultures and takes several weeks
to do so we can find out how significant
concern this particular variant is so it
is a safety first
approach we've done that before with
things like the the mink variant from uh
denmark and we're then able to relax it
unreasonably quickly and i think it's a
preference for doing that rather than
waiting and seeing until it's too late
we do have a plan b which is well
publicized that if we need to go to that
we we will and that includes uh mark
squaring uh everywhere and the like uh
and and more besides
well let's get some reaction now from
our political correspondent rob powell
hi rob uh grant shap's insisting that
the government is acting fast this is
preemptive should this reassure people
yeah not wanting to go anywhere near as
well the idea of moving to more domestic
restrictions because of this variant i
think part the reason the government
wants to be seen to be acting quick is
because whilst grant shap says the early
bird catches the worm frankly in the
[ __ ] in the past they've been criticized
for not acting quickly enough and
allowing variants like the delta variant
from india to spread quite rapidly so
grant chaps i think trying to reassure
people but i think realistically until
we know more scientifically about this
variant
i don't think people will necessarily be
reassured and of course the other big
political issue which remains a big
story here at the moment
the situation in the channel that letter
that boris johnson has written to
president macron it doesn't sound like
it's gone down very well with the french
i thought what was interesting about
that interview with grant shaps was how
much he said that action needed to be
taken in france that's where the issue
was well there's reports in the french
media
this morning that that letter that the
prime minister sent to emmanuel macron
french president has not gone down well
that the french interior ministry didn't
like it and as a result there were
reports that that meeting between pretty
patel and the french interior minister
on sunday has been cancelled now we
haven't confirmed that yet but if that
is true then that would be a very large
setback to trying to get some kind of
resolution to what is going on in the
channel given the amount when you read
that boris johnson letter when you
listen to grant shapes it's clear that
we are dependent on french cooperation
and collaboration to get this sorted
okay rob for now thank you
now scottish politicians have come
together to condemn a home office
decision to bus asylum seekers who
crossed the channel 500 miles north to
scotland for processing dozens of
migrants who would normally be held
close to where they entered britain are
being made to travel more than nine
hours to dun gavel immigration detention
facility in south lanarkshire
well i'm joined now by the snp finance
secretary kate forbes hello to you ms
forbes thank you very much indeed for
joining us uh this morning could you
just tell me to start with your main
concerns
well we've long been concerned about the
uk government inhumane and hostile
immigration system not just because it
is not compassionate but because it is
economically disadvantageous as well in
scotland we have
really stepped up when it came to
welcoming syrian refugees we are playing
our part in resettling refugees from
afghanistan but we remain
deeply unhappy with the way that the uk
government is managing the the process
of people seeking safe passage from
france and those when they arrive in the
uk who are being managed in the ways
that you outlined
so what's scotland doing to help asylum
seekers as the home secretary uh raised
the issue in the house of commons
yesterday glasgow is the only area in
scotland so far accepting asylum seekers
in the uk's government scheme
well we are also as i just said
welcoming
refugees from afghanistan all local
authorities really stepped up when it
came to
ensuring that syrian refugees could be
resettled at glasgow is right now a key
location when it comes to asylum seekers
but right now obviously it is a uk
government power but where we can play
our role scotland is the scottish
government is ensuring that there is
housing available that there is health
care provision made for those refugees
that are fleeing i think the bottom line
for me though is that we are seeing
reports on the front pages of newspapers
of mothers and babies drowning in the
channel because the system is not
working and we only see a few stories
that make it onto the newspapers
most of them don't so something
drastically needs to change
we don't have long so i'm just going to
cut in there if that's all right you're
right it is dreadful those scenes that
we're seeing on the front page of
newspapers are absolutely horrifying so
let's cut through the politics we need
cross-party solutions on this what would
you propose
so we do need cross-party solutions so
firstly i think that european leaders
need to get together to determine how
they are going to ensure safe passage
for those refugees and asylum seekers
that need it the most secondly we need
to see the uk take more refugees and
asylum seekers we know already that
germany and france
are taking it more refugees and that's
the second thing thirdly when refugees
and asylum seekers arrive they need to
be treated humanely we know about the
backlogs when it comes to the home
office we know that there is a hostile
environment that is an intentional
policy decision that needs to change
these are human beings so there's three
suggestions to start with
so obviously a bus ride a nine hour bus
ride as it's been described to scotland
after you've had to go through that
awful journey across the channel is not
ideal but it is safe that said the
facility where they're being taken in
scotland has been criticized for the
conditions so what's scotland doing
about that
absolutely and can i just be clear that
scottish politicians have criticized it
because it's a a home office facility so
we have long criticized the fact that
the uk government is processing asylum
seekers and refugees in hostile ways
that the facilities available are not
fit for purpose and you will find my
party has been very consistent that
although these facilities are based in
scotland they are not managed by
scotland we do not have the powers over
immigration and we have long called for
the facilities to be significantly
upgraded and refugees to be treated in a
more compassionate fashion
okay smps kate forbes thank you very
much indeed for your time today thank
you
well let's return to our top story now
the travel ban imposed on southern
african countries after a new covid
variant was just was detected we can
speak now to professor saleem abdul
kareem the former chairperson of the
south african government's ministerial
advisory committee on covid19 a very
good morning to you thank you for
joining us just how concerned are you
about this new variant that's been
detected in south africa
good morning and good morning to all of
the viewers quite concerned
put very simply we have been expecting a
new variant and we had in south africa
and in most of africa we put in place
the systems of surveillance to identify
a new variant as quickly as possible and
so we've been fortunate in this case
we've identified it quite early
if you look at this particular variant
we've only known about it for a few days
now once it was verified it was
announced so we know very little
about this variant in terms of its
behavior and how it's going to cause
disease but we can make some
extrapolations based on the mutations we
are seeing
now it has to be said that those are
just extrapolations they are not fact
but if you look at this particular
variant
it has characteristics and it has
mutations of all the other four variants
of concern
it behaves similarly to alpha
in some diagnostic tests it behaves
similarly it's got mutations that are
very similar to the beta and gamma
variant that confer some level of immune
escape
and it has mutations that are close to
the furan cleavage site of the virus
that enables the delta variant to be
more transmissible so it looks like on
the face of it that this variant has the
the two characteristics we've been most
concerned about which is high
transmissibility and some level of
immune escape having said that
i think it's important that you know
this variant will still be amenable to
all of our public health measures our
measures of mask wearing and ventilation
and social distancing would remain as
effective against this new variant as
they did with the others
even the vaccines are quite likely why
we don't know it is a fact it's quite
likely that the vaccines would remain
quite effective
against severe disease because that's
dependent on t cells which are not
impacted by the variance to a large
extent but there may be some level of
immune escape we might see more milder
cases in those who are vaccinated but
those who are not vaccinated we would be
most concerned about
now one of the reasons you detect var
new variants so successfully in south
africa is because you are very good at
genome sequencing uh do you think you're
victims of your own success to an extent
and that actually the variant could
already be being spread in europe and
the uk
you know if you don't look for something
you won't find it and if you do find it
you have to take the consequences of
what you find
that's not any reason why we would
compromise on our surveillance our focus
is to try and contain the new variants
if and when they arise
if countries choose to punish south
africa for that you know that's that's
what they wish to do it's not something
i'm you know i'm familiar with how they
want to control their pandemic the
reality is that when we look at a
variant like the beta variant or the
delta variant probably a good example
that within a matter of three weeks
it was detected in 53 countries
so even you know no matter what you try
to do against one or two or three
countries very soon the threat of the
possibility of introduction of a new
variant becomes widespread and it it
does so because
by the time we know about a new variant
even though we are really good at what
we do here in our country there's a unit
called crisp
uh headed by professor de oliveira that
really does this
fast and within days we know the results
but you still are in a situation where
when you know there's a new variant it's
already been spreading
for you know two three weeks so that's
the part of the challenge that we deal
with in surveillance and ultimately you
know every country is going to have to
become part and parcel of trying to
control new variants it's not something
we're going to do you know by just
locking the doors on others it's going
to have to be something we tackle
together
just briefly before i let you go do you
think in light of all that that the
invariant is already in the uk
i'd be surprised if it's not
because it's already in hong kong from a
traveler in south africa
i would expect it to be there
i don't know if it's there for sure but
that's my expectation
professor kareem thank you very much
indeed for your expertise today we
really appreciate your time
absolute pleasure thank you
just some breaking news to bring you now
devon and cornwall police
have said that a 24 year old cody
ackland has been charged with murder in
the connection with the disappearance
disappearance of 18 year old bobby ann
mccloyd in plymouth now we've had a
statement from devon and cornwall police
they've said a 24 year old man has been
charged with murder in connection to the
disappearance of 18 year old bobby ann
mcleod
cody ackland from the south way area of
plymouth has been charged with murder
and remanded in police custody he is due
to appear at plymouth magistrates court
on friday the 26th of november
the family of bobby anne have been
informed of this update and continued to
be supported by specialist officers
let's return now to the migrant crisis
boris johnson has written to president
emmanuel macron
setting out five steps he thinks both
sides should take to prevent more
crossing attempts and we can speak now
to an officer from the immigration
service union lucy morton a very good
morning to you thank you for joining us
of course
many people will remember well that the
home secretary authorized a very
controversial pushback
tactic against boats trying to cross
the channel and now border force guards
are considering taking legal action
over this what is it about it that makes
you so concerned
there are a very strict series of
constraints and times when it would be
possible to perform this tactic uh those
who are actually involved in this uh our
members on the on the maritime cruise
say that the constraints are such and
they are absolutely right that they must
be in place but they are such that in
practical terms actually this is never
going to happen and
you cannot push back a vessel which is
vulnerable and you can tell from all the
press stories that
you can see everywhere at the moment
these boats are overloaded not everyone
has life jackets there are women on
board there are children there are
vulnerable people on board
and it's not possible to push back a
vessel that's in that state but also the
other part of it is that you have to
push it back into a receiving french
vessel you can't just turn it back and
let it go it's got to be turned back
into a french vessel and the french are
absolutely clear they will not engage in
this process so if the french weren't
engaged we are not doing this there's
just no way for it to happen
you outline well the practical
challenges of of doing this do you think
you're also being asked to do something
inhumane here
to an extent
it's a difficult one to answer because
it depends on how you specifically
define inhumane forcing people into
these vessels in the first place is
inhumane
making them cross in these conditions
it's cold it's wet they spill fuel oil
frequently and lots of people come in
with burns on their legs where fuel oil
has soaked into their clothing
they're soaked in
forgive me it's a breakfast program but
you know they get sick in the boat uh
they're in the boat for hours there's
human um
debris the one for better word uh all
over their clothes that is absolutely
inhuman
i appreciate you outlining that as
difficult as it may be describing some
of the detail because
very often these people are sort of
described as faceless people or numbers
and statistics but you have to witness
the human reality firsthand in what
these people are going through and of
course one of the suggestions that the
prime minister has put to president
macron is to send over border force
officers to patrol french beaches how
would you feel about that
i'm not certain how the legalities of it
would work in practice and of course
although boris johnson has sent that
letter france has now broken off
communication and they're no longer
talking uh on this subject with us
because of it um i'm not certain how the
legalities would work we've gotten a
power of arrest in france and things are
quite violent uh on the french coast
there's the smugglers are getting
increasingly violent to encourage the
french police to let these boats go
there's a lot of money involved in this
and i certainly would not be very keen
for any of our members to be involved in
a situation
where people have weapons and our staff
do not
now the other big political story this
morning is this new uh temporary travel
ban that's been brought in
against six countries in southern africa
as someone who's had to
work on uk borders in the last couple of
years during the pandemic
in your experience
uh how much chaos and confusion does
this sort of measure throw up
it depends on the amount of checking
that waterfalls are being asked to do
and at the moment they've not actually
been asked to do any and so we won't get
flights direct from those countries uh
individuals who've flown from those
countries via a connecting flight will
simply come through in in the normal way
unless they do something to attract the
attention of a border officer for
another reason they're not likely to be
identified uh it's not clear yet um
whether there's going to be any extended
checking to ensure that individuals have
not arrived via a third country if that
is brought in if border force are
required again to extend the amount of
checks that they need to do for arriving
passengers at uh warts and seaports then
that will inevitably slow up uh the
process of people through the border and
it will result in an increased level of
queues but my understanding right at the
moment is that border force have not
been asked to take any part in ensuring
that individuals have not transited a
third country
and just very briefly before i let you
go of course there's a lot of finger
pointing between france and the uk about
what needs to be done about the
situation in the channel as someone who
actually has to work on the front line
of the uk border what would be the one
thing that you would want to see change
if something could be changed right now
it seems to us that the only thing that
the uk can control is itself
and so the only thing that that we can
really ask for is that the processes and
systems and resources within the uk are
adequately resourced for this so in
order to get people off the floor of tug
haven we need to be able to get them out
the other side of the process into local
authority housing those local
authorities need the funding to be able
to house folk we need resources to make
the asylum decisions resources into the
courts so that we can go through the
appeals process resources into
immigration enforcement so that once the
process is concluded uh we can arrest
these individuals and enforce their
removal if we have to if the only thing
the uk can do is control its own funding
and its own borders then let's resource
that properly
okay lucy morton we appreciate your
insight best of luck with your work
thank you very
much